merguez and Fontina stuffed croissants
okay big and bold when I was living in
France I stayed there for three years
once twice a week I treated myself to
the most amazing bold breakfast and it
started off with these Beauties here
mergys cheap but incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan my gaze in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't need any chili just a
touch of salt and pepper
you can smell the spice they're starting
to release all that wonderful oil that
flavor in there
add a couple of cloves I'll finely
sliced garlic
spread the garlic across the pan it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark Rich golden color
now take a look with the heat out for
the parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used in part flavor
during cooking but the leaves should
always be added just before serving to
give maximum color and fragrance
[Music]
and then finish that off with my capers
myself
now take your quest on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
I used to cringe when I saw the French
Cooks throw away croissants I used to
cry thinking oh my God
if you any idea what you're throwing
away in terms of flavor whatever you do
do not wipe out that pan dunk your
croissants mopping up all that amazing
flavor and caramelizing the inside
for that beautiful don't forget the lids
then get your thumbs and go inside the
croissant
all I want to do now is just create a
little pocket
and just manipulate the croissant now
this is where it gets exciting mix up
the Capers the garlic the sausages look
at the color
all that wonderful
delicious flavored oil now some cheese
but not just any cheese Fontina cheese
is like the number one cheese for
grilling and because it's a very rich
cheese you shave it thinner than you
would a white truffle but it gives a
really nice saltiness and a light Smoky
flavor
Touch of Pepper
with salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
nice
crisp
packs full of Flavor now top them
and that for me it's almost like being
back in Paris
except this time I don't have to share
them with the French
My ultimate big and bold breakfast
mergers and Fontina stuff croissants a
great way to start the day
boiled eggs with a soldier that will
make your taste buds stand to attention
there's something quite nostalgic about
a bald egg it's something that's never
lost it's magic when you slice that top
off and dunk that Soldier into the yolk
you can't mess with a deliciously runny
yolk but this is what I like to dunk in
it an anchovy Soldier anchovies into
pessim water no salt naturally yeah
anchovies are very salty so just a touch
of pepper
rich in Omega-3s the amazing tinned
anchovy is a natural flavor enhancer and
I use it to Pepper many a Savory dish
from roast lamb to the humble toasted
Soldier
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being on
the seaside now get your soft butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 anchovy if you send
butter that way you've got that real
nice salty creaminess mix that up
foreign
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish I'm in heaven the bread
this is a Sourdough delicious very
crusty take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
the smell of the anchovy oil is
incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil The
Secret of softly boiling an egg is to
place them into the water gently on a
spoon in and just tilt so they don't hit
the bottom nice and Light
up to the ball count to five turn the
gas down is it four and a half minutes
is it five minutes for soft boiled egg
I've cooked thousands of them and every
time
four and a half minutes whilst that's
boiling get your bread
spread that on there that is incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
in cyber I can't resist
oh my God
right
gas off one
Beauty in
two
I feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great Twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs with dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
of eggs benedict with Crispy Parma ham
the secret behind a great eggs benedict
is in the hollandaise so get your pan on
because I'm going to cook a hollandaise
over a rolling boil with a glass bowl
butter just put it on to melt
three egg yolks
separated from the white
tarragon vinegar pop that into the eggs
if you can't get turkey vinegar any
white wine vinegar will do just as long
as you've got that acidity in there give
some bite to the hollandaise put your
bowl over the Rolling Water
and just start whisking
if the eggs had Direct contact with the
gas pollen days will become scrambled
egg
once you've got that nice creamy texture
a nice thick Sauvignon start adding your
butter
nice and slowly
a couple of tablespoons of butter in
and give that a really nice mix
if you don't whisk it enough the egg
yolks don't take the butter it causes it
to split
it's more butter
using a big balloon whisk like this one
makes it easier to incorporate air and
helps prevent your mixture from
separating
all the butter in and the best way to
keep hollandaise nice and warm is just
leave it to sit over that nice warm
water bath and it just gives it a really
nice room temperature
a nice pinch of salt
fresh pepper and then fresh lemon juice
that just really makes it vibrant
exciting
and you want to it's like a sort of
thick custard I just want it to coat the
back of the spoon so it's like you're
giving the a nice glossy texture to your
beautiful poached egg now as the base
for the eggs benedict you cannot beat
English muffins but the ham
and we'll change I'm going to use the
most amazing Parma ham get your pan nice
and hot into the pan
it's like Posh rashes of bacon
beautiful
[Music]
ham fried nice and crisp though that is
incredible beautiful in salads fantastic
for eggs Benedict
[Music]
now keep that pan nice and hot I want
all that flavor on the Parma ham left in
there and rather than toast my muffins I
want to put the muffins into the pan I
want them sucking up all that wonderful
flavor from that crispy Parma ham
make sure your muffins are toasted
nicely this will prevent them going
soggy later
look at that nice and crisp
now water on to boil for the eggs nicely
seasoned really important and then just
a little splash of vinegar in the water
that helps the set the egg white in a
minute you crack it in
while the water heats up in the pan
there's time to get organized lay a nice
slice of ham on the base
now water's brought up to the ball turn
it down and then spin your water around
like a little whirlpool
don't get a little cup so you just drop
the cup in hello what happens to the egg
gets caught up in the turbulence of the
water
the secret is not the ball the water
rapidly because the strength of the ball
can literally explode your egg as they
start to move their way up to the top of
the water that's a indication that
they're cooked
take off any excess little bits of egg
white
and then out onto a piece of tissue
paper that just drains off excess water
that stops your muffin from going really
soggy
but look they're like little beautiful
mozzarella balls give them a little
season
left them on to a crispy Parma ham
peaceful
now get a nice spoon of your hollandaise
glaze over
try and do it in one glazing over the
whole egg
when I tell Jack Holly and Megan I'm
Matilda that we're cooking eggs benedict
for breakfast they bolt down the stairs
and let's be honest who wouldn't run to
sit in front of those
[Music]
I don't know
a special occasion breakfast that would
make anyone feel spoiled eggs benedict
with Crispy Parma ham beauties
[Music]